so you mentioned the plague by Camus
there's a lot of different ways to read
that book but one of them especially
given How It Was Written is that the
plague symbolizes uh Nazi Germany
and the Hitler regime what do you learn
about human nature
from a figure like Adolf Hitler that
he's able to
Captivate the minds of millions rise to
power and take on pull in the whole
world into a global war
I was born nine years after the end of
World War II
and I grew up in a generation that was
big you know with my parents who were
fixated on that
um on you know what happened and my
father
at that time the you know the kind of
the resolution in the minds of most
Americans and I think people around the
world
is that there was there had been
something wrong with the German people
that you know the Germans had been
particularly susceptible to this kind of
uh demagoguery and to following a
powerful leader and um and his
industrializing cruelty and and uh and
murder
and my father always differed with that
my father said this is not a German
problem
this could happen to all of us we're all
just inches away from barbarity and the
thing that keeps us safe in this country
are the institutions of our democracy
our constitution
it's not our nature you know our nature
has to
um
has to be restrained and it and that
comes through self-restraint but it also
you know the beauty of our country is
that we develop we devise these
institutions that are designed to allow
us to flourish
but at the same time on not to give us
enough freedom to flourish but also
create enough order to keep us from
collapsing into barbarity so
um you know one of the other things that
my father
talked about from when I was little you
know he would ask us this question
if you if you were the family
and Anne Frank came to your door and
asked you to hide her would you be one
of the people who hit her I risked your
own life or would you be one of the
people who turned her in
and of course we would all say of course
we would hide and Frank and take the
risk
um but you know that's been something uh
kind of a lesson a challenge that has
been uh that has always been near the
Forefront of my mind that if a
totalitarian system ever
occurs in the United States which my
father thought was quite possible he he
was conscious about how fragile
democracy actually is
um that would I be one of the ones who
would resist the totalitarianism or
would I be one of the people who
who went along with it would I be one of
the people who was at the train station
and you know Krakow or uh or
um or you know even Berlin and saw
people
being shipped off to camps and just put
my head down and pretend I didn't see it
because talking about it would be
destructive to my career maybe my
freedom and even my life
um so you know that has been a challenge
that my father gave to me in all of my
brothers and sisters and
it's something that I I've never
forgotten a lot of us would like to
believe we would uh resist in that
situation but the reality is most of us
wouldn't and that's a good thing to
think about
that uh human nature is such that we're
selfish even when there's an atrocity
going on all around us and we also you
know we have the capacity to deceive
ourselves
and all of us tend to kind of Judge
ourselves by our intentions and our
actions